my name is Alonzo Fulgham I am the vice
president for ird international in
arlington virginia i was asked the
question what is the one thing that
needs to change to create jobs i think
there are a couple of things that need
to happen to create jobs one is
government needs to create a policy
environment in which the private sector
in the name of the STS cannon thrive I
think they can do that through a couple
of interventions on the Hermit side as
well as ensuring that there's
environment for banks to lend to SMEs I
also think there are opportunities to
look at regional integration as a way
forward to addressing the problems not
only from a bilateral perspective
perspective but from a regional
perspective which is most important in
looking at this problem holistically for
the region
you